no toast mr. Colby goes off the mission
attention recently a new boss suicides a
yeah that's how you say my name is Munem
because like you might say something
something something like really weird
somewhere in the be like
I want my kids to realize that they come
from this place
and that they do have a culture they do
have a purpose here Manik Connie kunafa
cheek the top Oconomowoc jiwa meet
Japanese creator all my relatives all my
relations a thank you for all things
because I am think of all things I'm
thankful that I'm here I'm thankful that
I'm healthy and that my family is
healthy and that we're speaking language
to have the little ones here it's even
more comforting to know that they're not
embarrassed to learn it and they're
proud to learn their language and be
here with us